[Music]
and that is the
end of this series and the end of tsm's
perfect record
down to just bjergsen watching his
kingdom fall to ashes
[Music]
they're just not a good team anymore
it's just a beautiful 1v9 show bjergsen
all up the nexus is there they need to
cancel these backstage trucks he's
zipping back as fast as he possibly can
go
burke's in this here he's got the
shockwave again he used it but it takes
it the wrong way but bro
that's it i think we all know we're
getting carried by bjergsen right now
he's
smurfing it hard jerkshen wants back in
he has the ulti not gonna go now he is
scoops in three
look at that play they're gonna get a
whole lot done two kills picked up
make it a third huge out of the tsm mid
laner i hope he's able to keep that up
when they go to worlds uh because
he looks so good this guy just had
like he's really on one now i mean
bjergsen upped his level
tsm fans the championship drought is
over because last week the boys in black
became the 2020
lcs summer split champions as the nexus
falls tsm claim lcs title number seven
and after two years of missing worlds
two years of crushing losses
non-stop criticism and regrets bjergsen
easily the best lcs mid laner to ever do
it
is headed back to league of legends
biggest stage
to understand bjergsen's fall we have to
rewind back to 2014 when he first joined
tsm
who the [ __ ] are you i'm bjergsen back
to a time where he dominated the lcs
he was the league's best player
respected and idolized by fans and pros
alike
a respect that continues to this day
hitoki
yeah yeah i think he's okay
you i'm a free yes secretary
okay yeah maybe this year 2020. the only
black mark on an otherwise hall of fame
career was his lack of success at worlds
he only made it out of groups once and
that was in 2014
and in the process of his and tsm's
attempt to win at worlds and capture
glory
bjergsen's empire came crashing down
and at the end of 2017 after yet another
world's run
ending in the group stage tsm blew up
their beloved
super team the goal was to create a new
roster capable of competing
internationally with bjergsen at the
helm
but forget internationally this tsm
roster couldn't even compete
domestically
yeah you know but they dominated n a and
they took that for granted yeah they
they took that for granted but
i don't i i agree that's what they
overlooked i mean they're icarus
they tried to fly too close bjergsen's
stranglehold over na
evaporated in 2018. he got bopped from
the first round of the playoffs
and as a veteran who competed in every
lcs finals
and world since coming to na he'd have
to watch the game's biggest tournament
from home dsm fall it's two left alive
down to just bjergsen watching his
kingdom fall to ashes
over the course of the next two years
tsm cycled through a laundry list of
players
including four different junglers and as
the team's only constant
bjergsen took a lot of the heat for
tsm's decline so like the question
specifically is did they make the wrong
choice to build around bjergsen right
and that is that is hard for you to say
because
i think like bjergsen is getting
targeted a lot now as like oh
he's he's the common thread he's the
problem after failing to make worlds for
the second year in a row despite being
one of the best mid laners in the west
these results just weren't cutting it
and come contract negotiations in the
2019 offseason
everybody knew that bjergsen was sick of
losing the question was
would he stick around long enough to
change that but after months of sweaty
palms and waiting around to hear a
verdict
the worries of tsm fans everywhere were
put to rest
what you didn't think i was actually
going to leave right bjergsen resigned
to tsm
a two-year contract that would make him
part owner of the organization
it's safe to say that bjergsen wanted to
win and he wanted to win with tsm
and like years prior tsm surrounded
bjergsen with a new promising cast of
players
that looked strong enough to compete for
a title but the spring split came and
went
and tsm bombed out in fourth the
inhibitors are going
bjergsen's going he's just about gone
the exhaust makes it so he can barely
move the nexus turrets will fall
tsm can do nothing but look on
as flyquest put the finishing touches on
this game
the finishing touches on this season and
the finishing touches
on tsm as the community's expectations
of tsm
fell so did their opinions of bjergsen
sure he was still
great but his identity as the
untouchable star of
na's mid lane faded let's let's talk
about like the bjergsen jensen one i
think you guys having bjergsen at three
is so recently biased
it's awful it's almost off of last week
but in the midst of defeat
bjergsen gained the extra help he so
desperately needed
something in here
peter what are you doing in there i'm
teamless again dude can you help me
how long have you been teamless again a
few hours oh my god let's get you inside
the only player in na with a resume to
rival bjergsen's is doublelift
together they dominated na in 2016
and 2017 their individual firepower
eclipsing
every other player in the region as long
as lcs exists me and him will
be playing either with or against each
other for more trophies
i don't think that one of us is gonna
quit and especially i don't think
anyone's gonna quit when they're behind
and after two years apart bjergsen was
getting his greatest partner in crime
back
someone who he not only regarded as a
great teammate
but also a great friend i i've been
really good friends with
uh bjergsen and biofrost like for the
last
few years and
even when we were on teammates like we
we did play together and we were
teammates and we were really close but
then we weren't teammates we'd still
hang out and we'd be
uh you know we'd like vent to each other
and stuff and just talk about life the
once
unbeatable lcs duo reunited at long
last and come summer bjergsen looks
stronger than ever
while tsm as a whole struggled initially
trying to integrate doublelift but also
jungler spika to the team
bjergsen played like his old 1v9 self
the guy was single-handedly winning tsm
games on a regular basis
depending on the day usually he's been
he does really well right on like azir
uh like the control mages in general
but i feel like he doesn't really play
the
roaming champs or like he doesn't really
support his team usually or at least
that's what i see right now where he
he tries to 1v9 which is great i think
for tsm because in the past
he was playing like not even feels like
like galio or like
just like random champs and like maokai
made you know but right now he figured
out that
if he doesn't carry then psm is [ __ ]
right sure doublelift was back and yeah
he was playing well
but make no mistake about it throughout
the summer it was bjergsen who was not
only a cut above his
teammates but above the rest of the
league as well
tsm are deciding they want to start up
the baron
dardoch getting hit by the damage from
jericho who fires off the entire or the
alt
just lets it rip goodbye dardoch
tsm entered the playoffs as the fourth
seed and due to the strength of their
regular season finish
it was expected that they would run
through their first playoff round no
problem
especially considering how well bjergsen
was playing
all right all right well we're just
about at game time so i want to get
quick predictions from the three of you
based on your playoff brackets i know
it's where you're going in the series
it should be tsm across the board but
that's not what happened
instead tsm got beat down badly
get the passive going fox no bound up
again does pop the ulti but there's one
nexus tower down golden guardians gonna
pick up game
number one here to kick off their
playoffs ron what a way
to kick off the summer playoffs azalea
golden guardians
will take down tsm golden guardians
blasted tsm
three-nothing bjergsen looked
neutralized
and doublelift arguably had the worst
series of his entire career
i mean my thoughts on the on the game
well number one i think tsm's bot lane
is like
they played atrociously this series for
sure well tsm's championship hopes
weren't over yet they had a mountain of
best-of-fives to overcome to simply
qualify for worlds
let alone win a championship but
bjergsen wasn't done yet and neither was
the rest of tsm
first came their easy match against the
eighth seed dignitas
tsm will put in work on the nexus
turrets
they're gone before i even finish my
sentence
tsm will make swift work of dignitas
with a 3-0 victory
and will move on to the next round of
playoffs then
it was their rematch against golden
guardians a rematch that pushed tsm
to their very limits bjergsen wants back
in he has the ulti
not gonna go now he is scoops in three
look at that play they're gonna get a
whole lot done two kills picked up
make it a third huge out of the tsm mid
laner the re-engagement speaker the
re-engage for doubleth and who he will
lose
his life fbi could be next he is gone
golden guardians base open up it's tsm
knocking
next it was the world qualifiers match
against reigning lcs champions cloud9
taken down the nexus turret they will
take down
the remaining players on the cloud nine
roster
for the first time in seven years c9
will not be attending worlds and tsm
will claim their victory now qualified
for worlds after missing the tournament
in back-to-back
years tsm fans were happy as [ __ ]
but tsm as an organization was not done
yet
they were going to complete the losers
miracle run and bring back some [ __ ]
respect
to the name tsm there you go broken
blade falls brock's are running away
jensen barely going to be kept alive now
having to kind of weigh himself
he's somehow still alive speaking in hot
pursuit doubles got the slows
tsm has got him in their sight and that
is an ace for
team solo mig already the fight is three
for zero looking for a fourth doublelift
seems to kill credit on a solo broken
blade claims wild turtle and
ignore could only watch the runs away
and tsm
can look for the kill they're surely
gonna find it one more auto
and it's time to go for baron oh into
the back side and there's number two
harold's gonna be summoned for
not a whole lot out of santorin i think
he just pressed the button overall but
now he's done it by bjergsen as well
careful buddy
you're on a 1v3 slowed by fard and just
like
that tsm gonna pick up three kills in a
row
and the drake's right in front of their
eyes here they go to end the game
the last stand for santorin against his
old team
turtle the same but dublin has always
been the better 80 carry
shows it here in the game as the nexus
falls
tsm claim lcs title number seven
tsm's path to their seventh championship
took
25 different games five consecutive
series wins in the mvp of all five
series including the finals it was none
other than bjergsen
well after a grueling run through the
postseason and a full
five-game series finals player of the
series could be awarded to so many
individuals
for each of their individual play but
the votes were tallied and bjergsen will
walk away finals player of the series
with the domestic crown sitting atop his
head bjergsen's eyes are now
focused on league's biggest stage having
been away from international competition
these past two years
na's mid lane king has earned another
shot at finding glory
at worlds the kings of north america are
back reclaiming their throne here
it has been three long years for them
you